what I want to do in this video is
explore what happens when we get two
really really really small scales before
we even think about it
I want to familiarize ourselves with the
units here so we're all familiar with
what a meter is looks like the average
adult male is little under two meters if
you were to divide a meter into a
thousand units you would get a
millimeter and I think we probably know
what a millimeter is if you've ever
looked at a meter stick it still slot
the smallest measurement on that meter
stick so it's already pretty hard to
look at now if you were to divide each
of those millimeters into a thousand
sections you'd get a micrometer or
another way to think about a micrometers
it's one millionth of a meter so this is
kind of beyond what we're capable of
really perceiving if you were to take
each of those micrometers and divide
them into a thousand sections you would
get a nanometer so now we're at one
billionth of a meter you divide that by
a thousand you get a Pico meter you
divide so a Pico meter is 1,000 billion
1000 billionth of a meter or you could
say a trillionth of a meter you divide
one of those by a thousand and you would
get a femtometer so these are
unimaginably small things now once
you're familiar with the units let's
explore what types of things we can
expect to find at these different scales
and I'll start over here and I've
written them on the left as well but
it's more compelling when you see the
pictures we'll start over here with the
B and I've arbitrarily picked something
of this scale there's many many many
almost an infinite number of things I
could have picked up at this scale but
the average B is about two centimeters
long this B right over here it's about
it's about give or take it's about one
hundredth the length of the average
adult human being but once again the
honeybee not too exciting although it is
pretty exciting to see it zoomed in like
this but the honeybee is something that
we can relate to we've all seen
honeybees now what I want to do is zoom
in or look at something that's 50 times
smaller than a honeybee so something
that if I were if I were to kind of show
how big it is relative to this honey
it would look it would look something
like this I'm doing it very rough and
that is a dust mite and this right here
these are both pictures of dust mites
now dust mites look like these strange
and alien creatures but what's amazing
about them is that they are everywhere
they're all around us you probably have
many of them lying on your skin or
wherever right now which is kind of a
creepy idea but we're talking about
scale here and the average dust mite the
of average dust mite so we were talking
about centimeters before now we'll talk
about millimeters the average dust mite
is less than half of a millimeter or if
you want to talk in micrometers it's
about 400 micrometers long so this
length this length right over here is
about 400 micrometers so about 150th the
length remember this huge thing that I'm
showing right here this is a honeybee
it's about 150th the length of a
honeybee or maybe to put it in other
terms that you might be familiar with
this is a zoomed in picture of human
hair and you might say oh my god this
person has horrible hair but no if you
were to look at your own hair under an
electron microscope you'd be lucky if it
looked at this good this person actually
I've seen pictures of more damaged hair
than this this is probably smooth and
silky hair right here but the diameter
of human hair and this is on average it
depends on whose hair you're talking
about the diameter of human hair is
about 100 100 you can't see that in the
you can't see it when I write in that
color it's about 100 micrometers thick
that's the diameter so it's about 1/4
1/4 the length of a dust mite or if I
were to draw some human hair relative to
this honeybee it would look something
like this it would be about it would be
it would be about and I'm drawing the
whole hair so its width would be the
width of this thing that I just drew
remember we're looking at a honeybee
here looks like some type of giant but
it is a honeybee let's zoom in even more
so we started with the honeybee we
zoomed in by 50 to get the dust mite we
zoom in by another factor of 4 to get
the way
of human hair if we zoom in we're in the
micrometer range now if we zoom in by
another roughly another factor of ten we
get to the scale we get to the scale of
cells and this right here is a red blood
cell I think this is a white blood cell
right over here about six to eight
micrometers so once again if I were to
draw a cell relative to this human hair
it would probably look something it
would look something like this something
on a similar scale that we can still
kind of relate to is the width of spider
silk it's about three to eight
micrometers so if I were to draw some
spider silk on the same on the same
diagram it would look something it would
look something like this this is an
actual image of spider silk so once
again something that we can kind of
perceive you can bump into it you can
touch spider silk you can see it if the
Sun is reflecting just right or if it
has a little bit of moisture on it but
it's about the thinnest thing that
humans can perceive so and this is in
the kind of the ones of micrometer range
at that same range you start to have
some of your larger bacteria bacteria
can be anywhere from and I'm speaking
very roughly 1 to 10 micrometers so in
general they're smaller than cells most
bacteria are smaller than most cells and
just to figure out where we sit on our
scale have it over here so we started
off I want to keep reminding ourselves
humans you divide by a hundred you get
to the B so each of these slashes right
here dividing by 10 so this is divided
by 10 divided by 10 again you're divided
in size by 100 divided by 10 again you
get to millimeter you've divided by a
thousand divided by 10 again you are
doing tenths of millimeters which is
about the size of the human hair you
divide again by 10 you're going into
tens of micrometers by 10 again you get
into the micrometer range so now we're
talking about now we're talking about
human hair we're not human hair human
here weird up here we're talking about
cells we're talking about bacteria now
now things are going to get really crazy
now they're going to get really really
really crazy this was in the ones of
micrometer range now we're going to
start getting into the hundred
of nanometer range and just to get a
sense of things so remember a nanometer
is a thousandth of a micrometer or 100
nanometers would be a tenth of a it
would be a tenth of a micrometer and
this picture right here this big
enormous planet or asteroid looking
thing this is a white blood cell white
blood cell blood cell the enormous blue
thing in this picture and so if I were
to zoom out it would might look
something like this right over here but
what's really fascinating about this
picture for multiple reasons are these
little green things that are emerging
after that are after essentially
reproducing emerging from the surface of
this white blood cell and these things
right here these are AIDS viruses these
are aids viruses AIDS viruses so now if
we zoom in roughly another factor of you
know what about a hundred to a thousand
from the size of a cell you're now
getting to the size of a virus and all
of the genetic material necessary to to
replicate that virus is right inside
each of these little capsids right
inside each of these little green
containers so now going back to our
scale let me get my scale right over
here we are down to the scale of a virus
so we're in the hundreds hundreds of
nanometer range if we divide by ten and
then divide by ten you get to the
nanometer range and right in the ones of
nanometer range you get to the width of
the double helix of a DNA molecule so
this right here is if you were to zoom
in and this is an artist's depiction of
it obviously well this is not a picture
so to speak of a DNA molecule but the
width of this double helix is about two
nanometers or another way to think about
it about one sixtieth the diameter of
one of these viral capsids which is it
would have to be because it's going to
have to get all wound up and fit into
one of these viral capsids and DNA just
to make it clear this is just the width
of DNA it's much much much much much
much longer and we can talk about
in future videos so once again we're at
a very very small scale if you want to
think of it in terms of meters we're at
two billionths two billionth of a meter
you could you could put 500 million of
these side-by-side to get to a to get to
a meter or you could you could even
think of it this way this is two
millionths of a millimeter so once again
super small you could put these
side-by-side one DNA another DNA if you
if you made them touch you could put
500,000 next to each other in a
millimeter so this is unbelievably small
amount of space and now I'll introduce
you to another unit that's not kind of
in the conventional you know prefix
followed by meters and this is an
angstrom and 10 angstroms equal one
nanometer so the width of this DNA of
this DNA double helix would be two
nanometers or 20 angstroms now if we
were to divide again by ten you get to
something that's 2 angstroms or 0.2
nanometers wide and that is a water
molecule water molecule maybe instead of
using red I should have used blue or
something but this right here is the
oxygen oxygen and it is bonded to the
two hydrogen's it is bonded to the two
hydrogen's right over here so we're
getting you know this is beyond frankly
human perception I mean or even really
stuff that we can conceptualize not even
not to even speak of perception I have
trouble imagining how small we're
dealing with right over here we're
essentially dealing remember we're
dealing with less 1/5 of a billionth of
a meter or 1/5 of a millionth of a
millimeter something that I really can't
fathom but we're going to get even
smaller than that if we were to zoom in
on one of these hydrogen atoms and now
things start to get kind of abstract and
we start dealing in the quantum realm
and it's hard to define where one thing
ends and one thing begins and what is
real and what is not real and all of
that silliness but if we try our best to
do it if we were to zoom in and we were
to put some boundary on a hydrogen atom
because the electrons actually could
jump around anywhere but if we set some
boundary of where the electrons are most
likely to be found
the diameter of a hydrogen atom is
roughly one angstrom is roughly one
angstrom which makes sense from this
diagram - it's about half of the
diameter of this water molecule
what's extra crazy is one this atom is
super SuperDuper small something that we
can't you know this is one ten-billionth
one ten billionth of a meter or one ten
millionth of a millimeter so something
we really really can't fathom but what's
crazier than that is that it's mostly
free space we've gotten this small we're
trying to get to these fundamental units
and this thing right here is mostly free
space and that's because if you look at
an electron and the depth o when we say
radius here it's really hard to define
where it starts and ends and you have to
do some things related to the charge and
we're not even thinking about quantum
effects and all of that electron is has
a radius of 3 times 10 to the negative
5th angstroms and the nucleus of a
hydrogen atom which is really just a
proton has a radius a little bit and you
know don't even worry about this number
right here the general idea is it's the
same order of magnitude it's about one
ten-thousandth of an angstrom and just
to give a sense of what it's like if you
have the entire if you view the entire
atomic radius to be about an angstrom
kind of just have a conceptual for
conception for scale of the atom and how
much free space there's an atom if you
even want to we even want to think what
is free space
imagine a nucleus being maybe a marble
at the center of a football stadium of a
domed football stadium and imagine an
electron being a honeybee just randomly
jumping around random parts of that
entire volume inside of that football
stadium and obviously it's you know it's
a quantum honeybee so it can jump around
from spot to spot and it's not easy to
predict where it's going to go next and
all of the rest but that will give you a
sense of the scale of the electron and
the end the proton relative to the atom
as a whole but even more crazy it gives
you a sense it gives you a sense for how
empty how empty atoms and really all
matter really is